really most shooters are using light
machine guns
no different than the mini gun in the
original doom
this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and on this episode jonathan
discusses the history of the light
machine gun
how they differ from heavy machine guns
and of course how well they work in
video games
make sure to subscribe for more videos
featuring jonathan and if you'd like to
help out the royal army's museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
a light machine gun as the name implies
is lighter than a heavy machine gun
you bastards when machine guns were
first
created they were just machine guns so
automatic
weapons that fire for as long as you
held down the trigger or the firing
button or whatever
or ran out of ammunition hey player drop
the chips and get me some ammo
but they began to diversify as most
things do over time
well actually very early on hiram maxim
who invented the first
machine gun which would later become
known as a heavy machine gun
because it's big heavy and stays where
it is until a team of guys move it to
the next location
[Music]
ain't nothing but nothing over here
maxim also works on what would become
the light machine gun
so much smaller more portable
and physically lighter forms of the
machine gun which
if necessary one guy can operate
that's probably the best way to think
about a light machine gun
it's an automatic weapon automatic
military weapon
that one guy or a team of two at most
carries with them into battle into the
action
moving forward
so the other distinction the other way
to think about it is so the british
vicar's machine gun
was our standard machine gun before
there was such a thing as a heavy or a
light machine gun
and then the lewis gun was brought into
british service in the first world war
the vickers machine guns heavy water
cooled belt fed machine guns were taken
from the infantry squad
into a dedicated machine gun core and
used as effectively
miniature artillery pieces at like
strategic level
which left the light machine guns the
lewis guns
as part of the infantry squad
so a light machine gun is part of the
infantry squad
and it supports the rifles
and any other weapons that might be in
the squad and you'll typically have one
light machine gun
per squad squad can be anything from 8
to 12 men depending on the period in the
country
but you're always going to have some
sort of firepower
different countries did it different
ways but most of them had some form of
machine gun in the squad
now what makes things complicated is the
general purpose machine gun
so in the second world war that squad
machine gun
wasn't technically a light machine gun
it was a general purpose machine gun
because you could set that thing up
like a heavy machine gun or you could
carry it like a light machine gun which
is how it was
more often used so practical purposes
it's still a light machine
doesn't matter how it's fed it can be
magazine fed
belt fed doesn't actually matter what
caliber it is
the villar perosa what most people think
of as a submachine gun
was actually used by the italians as a
light machine gun
so like most types of firearms it's a
combination of its role
what it's designed to do so it's a squad
machine gun support weapon
but not not higher up like a company
level gun like a heavy machine gun
and it's also the technical capabilities
of it so it must have automatic fire and
it
nearly always has rifle caliber
ammunition as well
so it's a very very long-winded answer
to what is
on one level a very simple question it's
a lighter machine gun than a heavy
machine gun
but also quite a nuanced question in
terms of how different countries have
you used machine guns over time
[Music]
from the perspective of somebody who
knows about guns
and played quite a few games in my time
the light machine gun has always been a
bit of a weird fit
for well it's typically a first person
shooter maybe a third person shooter
that you're
using a light machine gun in they're
constrained by
by genre really unless you unless you've
got a full-on tactical shooter
where you're communicating with your
team and you're using something
approximating tactics
and you need suppressive fire to
actually
have an effect on the enemy whether
they're ai that respond to bullets
hitting near them
or whether it's human players afraid of
taking damage unless you have all of
that
the light machine gun is relegated to
being a super assault rifle
it's just an assault rifle with more
bullets
and that's why we see sometimes they're
relegated like the call of duty games
are a classic example of this
they're nerfed effectively so you you
might fire a
battle rifle it was a term i don't like
but a
full power cartridge firing automatic
rifle
you fire that and the bullets from that
do more damage than the ones from the
equivalent lmg i've seen that before
because they have to because otherwise
you would just carry the light machine
gun around
nothing else
some go for more that they try to make
them
work within a tactical sphere if you
like but it doesn't quite work so the
battlefield games
if your support you you can you can put
suppressive fire and it has an effect
um that really works better than most
games
really most shooters are using light
machine guns
no different than the mini gun in the
original doom
it's just a very high capacity
relatively high rate of fire
rifle machine gun whatever they're all
five bullets at the end of the day
if you'd like to support jonathan and
the work of the royal armouries check
out the links in the description where
you can donate
become a member pick up jonathan's new
book or subscribe to the royal armories
themselves
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you